Kirsten as much as I want to become that
billionaire I got some competition
namely hundreds of people like the ones
behind me here groups of up to 50 people
were seen at several convenience stores
earlier this morning both sides of the
state all before doors opened they got
good reason this is now the richest
jackpot in Lottery history at nearly 400
million dollars more than the previous
record Jackpot Nevada is telling us the
increased rewards mean increased
complications to play
when it's below a billion you could walk
in and walk out anywhere but once it
gets to like a billion and up
any place you go to is going to be the
same thing yeah and I'm pretty sure all
the people here have the same idea as me
trying to just go in and come out real
quick but it's not like that
now stores we went to today had wait
times reaching nearly an hour and a half
each ticket means a one in 292 million
chance of winning Powerball confirms the
most anyone's won since August was
around 2 million dollars now that
drawing happens tonight at 8pm Pacific
time back here in Arizona those nevadans
hoping to still play they still got a
little bit of time Arizona time they got
to get here by 7 P.M to pay to play
reporting live near the Arizona State
Line Ryan Matthey 8 News Now